so one of the things I wanted to do when
I got here is I definitely wanted to
work on the bags I took inspiration from
Canal Street
when you feel this
and I know you guys don't want to do it
at the look when have you ever seen a
Lloyd Bank do that butter
come on this is like you know what I'm
saying it's a different vibe
so we just leveled it up now we still
make the canvas ones but still at that
price point and then when you go in the
store you're not going to see this like
laying around you got to go in the back
like you would on Canal Street and then
you get the laminate and you look at it
and you like choose the difference is
this is really soft crushed buttery
leather and when it goes to production
it's going to be like two times as soft
than this but I want people to know like
you've leveled up this is a level up